for more on this were joined by Leslie
Sanchez she's a CBS News political
contributor and Republican strategist
and Philip bump national correspondent
for the Washington Post good morning to
you both Leslie let me start with you
the president's approval numbers are at
historic lows but he's still giving high
marks from his base what are you hearing
from Republican leadership sure there's
a there's a mixed review certainly from
Republicans they're excited that he's
been able to maintain the base he's done
some executive orders that have reversed
a lot of the Obama policies particularly
as it relates to regulation on
businesses they like that the Supreme
Court confirmation went rather smoothly
but when it comes to moving Lemaitre
legislation in Congress there's a lot of
consternation if your leaves muscling
his way through without garnering
political support and it's going to have
political damage in 2018 so the intra
parties squabbling in the Republican
Party on the hill has predated Donald
Trump in many ways right does anything
change that dynamic in the next 100 days
it's a great question I mean need your
absolute I mean John Boehner is no
longer speaker of the house because he
eventually just sort of gave up I'm
trying to get all the House Republicans
in line and going point in the same
direction we see that seems split now on
the health care bill right we see
there's this there's this caucus of hard
right Republicans who are have one
position then there are these moderate
Republicans and all these people of
course are out for re-election next year
they have a different position right and
Donald Trump has shown no history of
being able to work in any sort of
nuanced
political persuasion ability because
he's not from this world right and so to
ask him to come in and do that I think
is a big lift but it's it's it would be
hard for anyone it was well for John
Boehner it's hard for Paul Ryan I'm not
sure Trump can do it either Leslie what
are the Republicans in Congress want the
president to do particularly now with it
with this tax proposal coming up sure
they want him to get beyond showmanship
and get into governance and and I think
it's interesting because internally
you're hearing a lot of requests for the
president to stop micromanaging the
process now that he has a full cabinet
let him really rely on the resources
there to go through negotiate do the
deal-making but give political cover
especially to some of those vulnerable
members who are concerned about shift in
public opinion as it relates to too
see a the reforms you're seeing there
and the appetites changing on some of
these things are they any more
optimistic that tax the tax plan is
going to get through Congress I think
there is some optimism because of the
confirmation of the cabinet because the
president starting to get a rhythm
around that they really felt that the
micromanaging be kind of log-jammed
everything that they were trying before
he had a lot of people waiting to go to
work with the term and now they feel
they can do that how badly does the
president need this tax plan to go
through well I think he needs some sort
of victory I mean he certainly has
staked a lot on tax reform generally
talked about it a lot on the campaign
trail it seems like the sort of thing
that should be easy for Republicans to
unite around he needs to have some sort
of wind to the point that was just made
he spent a lot of time I think thinking
you just get a lot of stuff done right
at the front end because that's the
world he comes from comes with this
world a business he's the CEO he gets to
make these shot call these shots
I think he's learning very slowly this
is a slow process and a hundred days is
a very short period of time to get a lot
of these things done he needs to have a
win on tax reform or something but tax
reform seems like a likely candidate
let's see what happens on healthcare we
know that there was maybe going to be
another pass at that this week that's
gotten pushed off to the future
undetermined calendar date does this is
there a sense that there's momentum here
we see faction ality playing out as it
did the first time
sure initially I think you would have
heard Republicans Democrats the freedom
caucus came on board but public opinion
is shifting you're seeing a lot more
concern there's not an appetite among
Republicans to start changing a preview
no coverage for pre-existing conditions
that was really a deal breaker in many
senses and also looking at the
vulnerability of some of these members
if they take that vote is it really
going to address insurance premiums
lowering them the way they want they
don't have the confidence this is where
beyond showmanship into governance and
explaining those details to these
members and that's the question 2018
right Phillip if you if you alienate the
the moderates then you got the sorry if
you alienate one side you make problems
for the other other side there's an
election coming up next year there is
there's an election coming up next year
and I think it's important to reinforce
the point that Leslie just made about
the popularity of Obamacare right now
this is something that ever since the
election when people saw there was an
actual risk to this bill it has become a
lot more
popular in the public's eyes people
don't want to people don't like broad
change in general around health care
which is one of the problems Obamacare
the hair care had at the outset people
don't want that now either it's a big
big political ask and that's why I think
that it's probably smart for the
Republicans to try and move on to
something else
fill up the investigation into Russia's
in potential influence in this election
this past election still hangs over the
White House right where does the
investigation investigations Burrell
where do they stand right now exactly so
there are investigations ongoing on both
sides of Capitol Hill the House and the
Senate
we learned this week that the Senate
investigation though is probably pretty
severely understaffed relative to past
investigations but that said it's moving
forward Sally Yates the Attorney General
who is let go by the administration is
going to come and testify before both of
those investigations there is some
indication that the public is starting
to get a little tired of it there's a
poll out this week from Fox News showing
that 57% of the country thinks it's time
to move on but one thing we learned if
you look at the Benghazi hearings that's
where the whole Clinton email server
thing came from so you never know what
you're going to dig up so there
certainly is value for the Democrats and
trying to keep this investigation going
as long as possible
you never know that over to a bumper
sticker that every car in the last two
years
could be the bumpers there goes Leslie
Sanchez and develop bomb thanks for your
time